when the crisis hits
there are three types of people i don't
want you to be panicking right oh my
gosh what am i going to be doing pat
look there's those that shut down
some of you guys are going to watch this
and you already have anxiety like oh my
gosh
what's going to happen people are you
listening to this look what do you want
patrick saying invite him oh my gosh
what are we going to do babe
yeah this is this happens
okay the the only crazy thing about
recession is the following thing that we
need to know about with this part is
this
do you know when's the longest in the
history american history since 1776.
okay
we can go 1851 when we started tracking
recessions
do you know what's the longest america's
ever gone without a recession
do you know the longest we've ever gone
without a recession 14 years you know
what year it was not in the 1800s not
1920s
not 1950s not 1980s the longest we've
ever gone without a recession is today
14 years
we're overdue for a recession
and our politicians on both sides have
been saying nah next term
nah next time i need to get reelected
nah next term
it's coming
it's here you got to be ready for it
it's part of the economic cycle fyi the
longer we wait to go through the
recession the bigger it's going to be
we have to kind of go through it and
buckle down the shortest recession last
six months the longest lasted 43 months
the 43 months was a depression
no one knows if it's going to get that
ugly or not but some are saying it could
get that ugly nobody knows but that's
pure speculation all i'm saying to you
is
a recession is overdue and the data
points to it coming here very soon as of
july 1st according to the definition
it's officially recession time how long
it's going to last after july none of us
know we know it's going to be at least
six months up to 43 months but some
people are going to watch this and
they're going to panic and they're going
to shut down what do i do what do i do
what do i do unfortunately 80 of the
people are gonna join the panic camp
you just don't want to be part of this
camp
because this is probably the best season
for you to finally create some wealth
for you and your family
this is a very very good time business
insider came up with a story today
talking about the fact that remember
when everybody was telling you to shop
your resume and go leave your company to
another company to get going to get your
money and go get your raise and all that
stuff guess what all those people that
said that to you they were wrong today
businesses sat our article talked about
that
so if you were somebody that were
working out of place you're loyal you're
bringing value getting better you're
learning new skill sets markets gonna
favor you okay but don't be the person
that shuts down the second kind is
people
who who just survive and there's like oh
my god i don't know i'm just a survivor
i'm just hoping i survived this and then
there's those who come out stronger my
idea is
just like when i had this in o-1 when
this happened or oh wait i wanted to
come out stronger and my encouragement
for you is to do the same as well so now
going back to what elon musk said
remember number one you the leader of
your household
if you're
the father or the mother and you got
kids you are the leader of the household
what predictions are you making for your
family's finances you got to make some
predictions
if you're the leader of the company that
you lead the visionary what's your
prediction
hey mr mrs leader what do you predict is
going to happen you can't just say
everything's going to be all right
you're sure
you sure
is that what great leaders do
or is that what scared leaders do
you got to make some predictions what
are your predictions i just gave you
mind what my prediction is what's yours
based on what you just learned you just
learned from today okay so number one
make your predictions number two
prepare for what's to come if it does
number three persevere because you come
out of this
strong and you do it right you'll come
out a winner okay so now a few things
number one never been a more important
time to start a side hustle never
ever been a more important time to start
a side hustle guys when 9 11 happened
you know what i was doing in la i was
selling three shirts i'd go to downtown
l.a because i was broke and nobody would
hire me i'd go to downtown l.a at four
o'clock in the morning
and i would buy these three shirts it
was right after 9 11. one of the shirts
was united we stand and another one was
the american flag and the third one
which was my best seller you know what
the title on the bestseller was osama
yomama i'm not even kidding with you i'd
buy these shirts for two bucks i would
sell them on roscoe and rasita
for 15 bucks a shirt
20 for two shirts and i would just go
like this because i needed a side hustle
i would sell clip and talks to put on
before they had speakers on phones there
was these things you would put on your
nokia 5960 i think it was called and you
would have speaker on the phone you put
it on 88.7 do you remember those days i
would sell those products buy it for
five bucks sell it for 20 bucks it
didn't matter i had to have a side
hustle i got licenses so i can sell
things to make money today's a time to
have a side hustle to make some income
for yourself number two collaborations
find the right partnerships go to places
like today i was talking to one of our
uh
ceos of a company who runs a real estate
company doing 40 million a year i said i
would go to conor he's going to the
vault conference that we're hosting
which we're going to announce here to
speakers at the vault conference which
is pretty i didn't even tell you we're
going to announce speakers
i said when you go to the vault
conference what i want you to do is
anybody that says they're in real estate
and they run a good-sized business
mortgage real estate escrow get
connected with all these guys and create
a group whatsapp with 10 20 30 40 other
people that individually run their
businesses and communicate with each
other what you're doing that's working
for you because collaboration is a very
very key today this is the wrong time to
be a loner going through this by
yourself you're going to drive yourself
insane if you go through this by
yourself when i was in the army they
would talk about the body system always
have a buddy this is a time to have your
body system within the industry that
you're going through three save that
money
no more ferragamo right now you don't
need a ferragamo build you can buy a
regular bid for 40 bucks you don't need
no ferragamo shoes go buy regular shoes
99 bucks go buy them at a discount go
buy them on ebay there's a lot of one on
discount you don't need a rolex today
you can do with your apple watch maybe
you don't even need an apple watch it he
can go with a seiko you don't need to go
buy that 4 000 cannoli suit you'll be
okay with the hugo boss 9.99 don't get
the hugo boss get a three-day suit
broker the point is the chanel purse has
got to take a break the louie's got to
take a break
obsessed with saving money because a lot
of stuff is going to be on sale
a lot of stuff is going to be on so i'm
a card collector as well
cards are about to go through a whole
different mess themselves and i made a
lot of money off baseball cards
there's gonna be so many things on sale
you want to make sure you have the cash
to be able to capitalize off that
because your family
the person that's the 57 euro version of
you is hoping you capitalize during this
market
your grandkids one day that you don't
have yet they're begging you
mommy daddy grandma grandpa when you
were 28 years old please stay focused
during this time grandpa
please stay focused during this time
grandma please go above and beyond
because i'm relying on you to make the
right choices today because that's going
to allow me to go to the schools so my
life can change because grandpa made the
right choices
save that money today cash is king today
cash is king today recreate yourself
today for you surprise people when they
see you and they don't even recognize
them i've never heard them talk like
that before
look at this we've been at 5 000 after
five minutes into this hasn't changed
you know how many people are thinking
this right now all of the 5 000 plus
your spouse's partners there's probably
25 30 000 people right now watching this
presentation as we're going through it
make a decision to recreate yourself so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
you